here right now with reaction all that
talks News national security strategist
former deputy assistant to the president
talked to Sebastian corker dr. Gorka let
you respond to that we have to import
uranium into this country and yet
Putin used we knew all these things were
happening all these crimes committed he
built a network in the United States why
anybody would ever allow a foreign
entity to have any interest in uranium
winning we need more and we have to
import it never made sense did it not at
all not only do we need it there is
legislation that is active today that
says America should be absolutely
self-sufficient on uranium it is such a
strategic asset that we must not rely
upon anybody else and Hillary Clinton as
the chairman the chairman of that
committee approved this deal the
question is how far up the chain does
this go does it go up to President Obama
as well and if you look at the
statements coming out of Hillary in the
last 48 hours to quote the good Bart the
lady doth protest too much the heat is
on and finally we have a chance
I know Fox viewers have been very very
cynical that these people are Teflon
coated and they never pay the price for
their crimes but it seems as if finally
under a trump administration this
rampant criminal cartel which goes by
the name of Clinton will finally see
some form of justice in the near future
let me dovetail into the issue of
Senator grope Al Franken in that
disgusting picture your thoughts if you
know there's this somebody said to me
tonight you know poor judge Moore all
you have to do is change ticket and
become a Democrat because then he'd be
Teflon coated as well at the end of the
day these things are outrageous the fact
that the left seems to have double
standards on these issues it's only
Republicans that get in trouble for
these kinds of behaviors these are all
inexcusable any kind of sexual act of
this nature whether it's an assault or
whether it's something that simply
shames a woman afterwards taking
photographs while they're asleep of a
sexual nature Al Franken
I want to
not just the GOP I don't just want to
see the Rhinos I want to see the
Democrat senators call for Frank's Frank
Al Franken's removal resignation and
read when you when you put when you talk
about a double standard all the years
Democrats have bent over backwards they
have thread every needle they have
skated every razor's edge so they could
defend the Clintons and there was in
this sense we do there was collusion
with Hillary stole the primary from
Bernie but we knew that there was media
collusion to help Hillary win and that
was proven in no uncertain terms via
WikiLeaks and I you know you watch all
of this and but here we are 30 years
later and they did it all the way up and
through and until last year's election
and we have to wonder how do they hold
the mantle in their minds when it's not
accurate that they're for women's rights
gay and lesbian rights and and and
freedom of religion and she thinks money
from those other countries you have
another award from Hillary today she's
you had a whole hit squad to go out
there bimbo eruptions smearing all those
women that did speak out your thoughts
they preach one thing and they do the
opposite with the Democrats are supposed
to be the party of sexual equality of
trans rights of protecting the victim
and what do we find exactly the opposite
it's a good rule of thumb when they
accuse somebody else of doing something
they're probably doing it themselves but
the interesting thing Shawn to look at
that article in The New York Times just
two days ago calling Bill Clinton out
for his being a sexual predator it looks
as if Hillary and Bill are past their
sell-by date they're no longer relevant
to the DNC and they're gonna be thrown
under the bus it took 30 years but it
might be happening dr. korkor thank you
for being with us